[Musique]
d'un point de vue on a la joie et
l'honneur de recevoir ce soir françoise
degois une bonjour chers il paraît que
vous êtes sur un livre plein de
révélations dont on va beaucoup parler
la semaine prochaine c'est vrai où il
faut pas écouter ce que disent les
journalistes à nos non pas du tout de là
vous parlez du livre de ségolène royal
absolument je ne sais pas du tout ce
qu'il y aura dans ce livre je ne suis
pas sûre ce livre est toute façon si je
l'étais je vous dirai rien en attendant
on se consolera on pouvait toujours
tenté en se consolant en lisant les
derniers ça va ça date un jour des de
france on imaginer si décisif euros et
bah il est très heureux aujourd'hui je
pense que henry est prémonitoire
voilà justement on va en reparler tout à
l'heure pierre vermeren est avec nous
aussi il faut absolument lire vos livres
ça vous aliments bonjour je pensais pas
que vous diriez l' inverse
non seulement celui vous allez faire
paraître la semaine
à la fin du mois d'octobre si si les
infos sont bonnes sur les dissidents du
maghreb
il faut lire également la france en
terre d'islam et surtout surtout amont
de mon point de vue le choc des
décolonisations c'est le livre qu'il
faut lire pour faire le vrai bilan de la
décolonisation c'est passionnant c'est
édifiant un mode d'ailleurs l'état a
condamné à indemniser un harki ça vous
paraît une bonne mesure
récemment il est temps parce qu'ils sont
tous morts bientôt mais c'est une
politique
oui je sais pas j'ai pas suivi ce
dossier
moi je laisse les spécialistes de la
guerre d'algérie traiter de ces
questions il y en a beaucoup mais dans
une série de l'après d'ailleurs donné
quand même sur des périodes de très
anciennes maintenant mais c'est bien si
ça doit être fait que ce soit fait
maintenant ou jamais on va continuer à
suivre sa alexandre malafaye est
également que vous êtes présidente du
think tank si nos pierres et on est
heureux de vous retrouver ici sur le
plateau du point de vue comme on est
heureux de retrouver marc landré chef du
service économie français en reparlera
avec vous notamment de la cour des
comptes qui vient tatillonne et cette
fois ci sur la sécu c'est l'une des
infos de l'après midi l'autre infos de
la journée c'est ce qui s'est passé à
colombey-les-deux-églises ce matin
emmanuel macron qui est venu visiter
le
fonde la tombe du fondateur de la
cinquième république et qui a eu des
propos peu amènes il faut le dire avec
certains habitants de
colombey-les-deux-églises on va y
retrouver
on va y revenir par dont on va se poser
une autre question comment va la vème
république 60 ans après les politiques
ont appris à l'aimer pas tellement les
français puisque 56 % avouent qu'ils
n'apprécient pas cette ce régime
dites-nous cvo si c'est votre cas aussi
vous appréciez la vème république
dites-nous également si vous avez bien
entendu le dernier discours de gérard
collomb
quand il a quitté hier la place beauvau
on écoutera en tout cas on réécoutera le
désormais ex ministre de l'intérieur et
son diagnostic alarmant sur la sécurité
des français
êtes vous d'accord dites le nous en tout
cas vous n'êtes pas rassuré c'est ce que
révèle un sondage hoxha qui sera publiée
à partir de ce soir par le figaro
autre question faut-il plus taxer
l'alcool et encadrer les dépenses des
médecins de ville
c'est en tout cas le nouveau traitement
que préconise la dernière ordonnance de
la cour des comptes pour la sécu malgré
des comptes en équilibre
votre avis sur la question on en
débattra avec nos invités tout comme on
reviendra sur les un an du mouvement mis
tous at il vraiment changé les
comportements
c'est la question qu'on pose sur
lefigaro.fr celle qu'on vous pose et
composera à nos débatteurs
mais d'abord direction colombey les deux
églises
alors on a entendu ce matin emmanuel
macron rendre hommage au général de
gaulle
il va également s'exprimer dans les
minutes qui viennent devant le conseil
constitutionnel pour dire tout le bien
qu'ils pensent de cette constitution il
a commencé à le dire ce matin mais je
voulais vous interroger sur un autre un
autre événement qui s'était qui s'est
passé ce matin puisque emmanuel macron
été interpellé par une par une retraitée
et il a déclaré ceci le petit fils du
général de gaulle m'a dit tout à l'heure
que la règle devant son grand père était
vous pouvez très librement parler la
seule chose qu'on n'a pas le droit de
faire c'est de se plaindre je trouve que
c'est une bonne pratique qui avait le
général le pays se tiendrait autrement
s'il était comme ça autrement dit s'il
ne fallait pas se plaindre
françoise degois est ce que c'est votre
avis ou bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
désormais une macro nahd
oui si les maquereaux nahd je me demande
quel est ce mystérieux syndrome dont ils
frappent emmanuel macron chaque fois
qu'il sort immune gifle je ne sais pas
pourquoi et plus on lui dit de changer
de comportements d'attitudes de pas
prendre les gens de haut ne pas faire
preuve d'arrogance je veux bien qu'on
aille chez le général de gaulle sur la
tombe n'est pas de gaulle qui veut ça
c'est la réalité puis de gaulle s'est
produit d'une histoire particulière d'un
siècle particulier vous pensez comme le
rythme non mais je pense je pense
c'était une certaine tenue l'inspiration
golly c'était une dignité porté par le
président de la république
l'inspiration golly c'était un président
qui imposait le respect parce qu'il
était respectable
oui autrement dit quand on leur en veux
qu'ils disent assez qui pensent que
emmanuel macron n'a pas toutes ces
qualités là c'est pas le problème d'être
respectable ou pas moi je juge pas en
ces termes je dis simplement qu'il
valait macron fait beaucoup d'erreurs il
a sa jeunesse pour lui il a une attitude
et un comportement à l'évidence que ce
pays ne comprend pas ne comprend plus et
n'accepte pas donc quand le monde entier
vous dis change quelque chose est bien
l'essentiel c'est quand même de le
changer
c'est à dire que il recommence dans ses
travers de ce que parce qu'il faut voir
le tout les changes il engueule une
retraitée qui est modeste
on ne se plaint pas et puis c'est pas
vrai que leur retraite ne baisse pas il
ya quelque chose qui complètement
déboussolé chez ce jeune président je le
redis n'est pas de gaulle qui veut pour
rentrer dans l'histoire il faut prendre
plus d'épaisseur il faut aller dans des
sentiers sur lesquels il ne va pas il
faut rentrer profondément dans les
dossiers moi j'ai sentiment de voir un
starter delà de la silicon valley qui
survole les dossiers pyatt qui est un
peu de talent mais là ça suffit pas on
est à la limite alors sur justement
cette analyse d'un start up silicon
valley je vais demander ce qu'en pense
le chef du service économie du figaro
contredit pas totalement mais un petit
peu quand même ne serait ce que pour le
plaisir du débat on est là pour ça je
pense qu'il connaît les dossiers mais
simplement il connaît pas les gens et à
défaut les connaître il les aime pas ici
parce que je vis actuellement sur le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités ou sur les
pensions elle ne baisseront pas elles
vont être revalorisées moins que ce
qu'elle aurait dû l'être si elle était
restée indexés par rapport à l'inflation
donc c'est comme françois hollande c'est
comme celle sa taille ne dit pas
d'erreur il dit il fait des mensonges
par omission ou alors mais c'est pas
l'iran dans les dossiers il les connaît
techniquement en revanche il n'aime pas
les gens ils ne les connais pas il les
prend de haut je vous la corde c'est
vrai et il a une caractéristique c'est
que plus on lui dit d'aller à droite et
à gauche
il est une caractéristique c'est qu'il
déteste qu'on lui dise ce qu'il doit
faire et donc il va faire strictement le
contraire est donc là on lui dit et
arrogant tu parles mal aux gens
tu es tu es trop potins et bat hiller
mais ça fonctionne comme ça mais à ceci
près il se trouve que j'ai déjeuné ce
midi avec un avec un grand patron et je
lui disais mais benalla à la démission
de colomb est à l'international est ce
que ça imprime une disent pas du tout ce
qu'un prime aujourd'hui maquereau en
reste adulé à l'étranger parce que c'est
un président jeune ça président café les
ordonnances travail
c'est un président qui a fait la réforme
de la sncf c'est un président qui a
modifié l'image de la france à
l'international
le reste ce sont des gens suivent jeu
même si je pense au contraire que des
péripéties de revers leur haine c'est
l'image que on a à l'étranger et en
particulier dans un monde que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils aient le monde
arabe le mans du maghreb vous avez les
le monde arabe le maghreb d'abord d'être
et ça dépend des pays il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'opinions qui s'exprime aussi
bien dans la population que dans le
parmi les chefs d'état non il ya une ya
pas d les gens ne comprennent pas je
pense qu'ils sont assez intrigué parce
qu'au fond ils ont été habitués pendant
longtemps avoir des non pas des experts
mais des gens qui connaissaient très
bien le monde arabe
ça a été le cas jusqu'à jacques chirac
et depuis ils ont l'impression d'avoir
des gens qui sont au mieux dans une
certaine ignorance au pire sous
influence et donc je pense que vous ne
parliez pas ça vous parliez des chefs
d'état occidentaux vous parlez des états
unis d'un certain nombre de pays mais
dans le monde arabe se dit la france a
encore un rôle important
dans certains pays on va essayer d'en
tirer profit
affaire intérieure de la france
n'intéresse pas ce qui intéresse c'est
la politique que mène la france en syrie
c'est les relations qu'elle entretient
avec les états du maghreb avec l'egypte
mais les réformes intérieures et
notamment les réformes libérales ça n'a
aucun sens chacun vaut mieux bien sûr
mais parce que vous mmes empêcherait pas
de penser que par exemple en algérie on
suit on scrute tout ce que fait
le premier intérêt les questions
relatives à l'islam les questions
relatives à l'immigration
voilà ça ne sonnait pas les questions
liée au pouvoir d'achat des français ça
c'est une autre affaire on est nôtre en
tout cas sur la petite phrase de manuel
macron qui dit les françaises prennent
trop j'ai l'impression fait alors que
c'est emmanuel macron qui se plaint qui
se plaint des français parce que
peut-être qu'il a vraiment du mal parce
que à force de les attaquer de les
mettre en question
ça veut dire qu'il les comprend pas il
les comprend pas parce qu'en fait banal
mâcon n'a jamais été un chef célèbre une
fois qu'il est chef est il est en plus
il est super chef il fait ce que font
les mauvais choix fyfe chef voilà
or un bon chef ça fais pas ça et si on
fait l'analyse et que le général de
gaulle alors ce qu'on attend d'un chef
c'est un chef c'est vous protégez pas le
traiter le haut commandement militaire
ça de gaulle savait faire oui mais je
pense que de gauche parle de moi et là
je pense que le général de gaulle
n'aurait pas fait ce qu'a fait parce
qu'en tant que chef militaire il aurait
pas fait ce qu'il a fait c'est à dire
une exécution stream en place publique
du chef
je soumets à pierre vermeren ce que vous
venez de me dire oui mais je vois pas on
peut refaire l'histoire et la faire
parler mais on sait d'où on vient et on
sait aussi ce qui s'est passé vraiment
pour faire germer je veux dire je
m'intéresse comme au rôle du chef un
vrai chef
ça fait quoi ça respecte les gens ses
collaborateurs ses équipes deuxièmement
ça les protège c'est le rôle qu'on
attend d'un chef et troisièmement c'est
les motive ça les entrées et après bien
sûr sa voix et ensuite ce que je voulais
rajouter c'est que moi je crois qu'il
est maintenue le maquereau qui le
chantre du nouveau il est exactement
dans le piège des anciens et avec cette
espèce d'illusion dans lequel on
entretient les français du présent de la
vub star est alors avec ce sentiment
incroyable de dire voilà sous prétexte
que je parle avec des français je touche
des français et bien en fait j'ai
emprunté d'enfants savais pas que je
parle aux français je vais je suis en
revient avec tous les français c'est pas
vrai je pense que ça c'est une illusion
et je pense qu'au xxème siècle on attend
autre chose et que faire de la politique
autrement c'est pas voilà faire du
tactile et faire de la poste ont pâti
d'abord je voudrais dire une chose sur
ce que ressentie chef d'entreprise c'est
pas du tout vrai la somme de papier qui
arrive depuis quinze jours de l'ensemble
des journaux européens y compris des
journaux allemands sûr que se passe-t-il
avec macro on comprend plus rien l'image
mac rend à l'étranger
elle commence à s'abîmer les états unis
au mieux savent à peine qui sait
demandé dans l'arkansas de situer paris
la france va tous les diplomates sont
les na'vis et les deux mais c'est normal
estime max wissel les investisseurs
encore une fois soyons dans le réel
il est détesté en italie il n'est pas
aimé en espagne il commence à être mal
jugé en allemagne emmanuel macron donc
après les investisseurs j'attends les
résultats vous savez là ma chronique
portrait mieux s'il y avait des
résultats
la réalité c'est que pour le moment il
n'y a strictement aucun résultat aucun
résultat probant le maximum d
investissement vous savez bien des
investissements étrangers ça c'est fait
aussi sous le nom d' ado hollande en
donc il n'y a pas cette idée que nouveau
monde que macron savall étant aussi de
pib de pouvoir d'achat par sa
personnalité pour revenir sur macro et
la vème république puisque c'est le cas
du débat je voudrais vous soumettre oui
mais ça c'est vous répondre à ma
question d'accord même si georges
marchais sans réponse c'est un voilà
donc ce plateau sera tenu pour l'instant
et justement il ya quelqu'un qui a
souvent protester contre le caractère
antidémocratique ou en tous les cas un
peu trop autoritaire de la vème
république
c'est notre ami le constitutionnaliste
olivier duhamel notre avec ce qui n'est
souvent à votre place et il a été
longtemps partisan de la sixième
république et on lui a demandé l'autre
jour dans le cadre d'une émission qu'on
a faits qui est à retrouver sur
figaro.fr sur la vème république sait ce
qu'il serait aujourd'hui pour encore une
sixième république et ce qu'il pensait
bien qu'elle le bilan qu'il tirait des
institutions je vous propose d'écouter
dans l'idéal je suis partisan d'une
vième république d'une république primo
ministériel d'un premier ministre qui
dirige le gouvernement et qui
responsable en france c'est impossible
de passer à ce type il faudrait une
révolution ce qui n'est pas souhaitable
c'est impossible parce que les français
adorent l'élection présidentielle et
parce qu'on n'imagine pas un prisons de
la république disant je viens d'être élu
mais c'est très mauvais ce système il
faut tout changer
il ya beaucoup d'efforts de
démocratisation a réalisé encore on a
une assemblée nationale qui est quand
même très peu représentative non
seulement politiquement mais même
socialement on a une
trop faible autonomie des ministres il
ya des progrès à faire pour que ce
présent ces listes soient pleinement
démocratique mais globalement je
maintiens mon anniversaire et je dis
c'est pas parce que tu es vieille que tu
dois pas t'améliorer pierre vermeren
la vème république au mois elle a eu le
mérite également de résister à un
premier choc c'est celui de la
décolonisation où elle en est sûre elle
en est même ni elle en est même né mais
vous savez entre le régime des années 50
et où fin 50 des bises et 60 et le
régime aujourd'hui on dirait qu'on a
déjà changé de république en réalité on
a gardé le bouclier institutionnels mais
quel rapport entre la pratique
présidentielle et gouvernementale du
gouverneur gouvernement actuel et celle
de de gaulle dans les années 60 on a
déjà changé
alors c'est peut-être cinq ennemis ou la
prochaine sera peut-être la septième en
ai déjà marre la sixième
parce que quand vous voyez un président
qui descend comme ça qui parle qui
échangent avec des propos assez
désobligeant vous parliez tout à l'heure
des retraités mais quand on sait qu'un
retraité sur deux vit avec moins de 1000
euros je sais pas moi comment si nos
gouvernants savent ce que ça veut dire
de vivre avec 1000 euros et c'est le cas
de millions de gens en france
franchement c'était peut-être y avait
peut-être déjà sept cette pauvreté dans
les années 60 mais il y avait plus de
dignité il y avait plus d'attention à
l'autre en été dans les trente
glorieuses
justement je voulais vous soumettre les
résultats du sondage qui a été fait par
aux docks ça pour le figaro juste à
l'occasion des soixante 60e anniversaire
de la vème république et on voit que 56%
des français sont peu attaché à ce
régime
quand on regarde dans le détail ce qui
est très intéressant c'est qu'on voit
par exemple que c'est notamment dans les
partisans du rassemblement national et
ont remis ça au fait qu'il n'ya pas la
proportionnelle est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui pour justement la rendre
plus démocratique il faudrait instaurer
la proportionnelle françoise dost
je pense que tout est lié la sait très
bien qu'on tombe de ce 60e anniversaire
de la constitution
il se passe ce qui s'est passé également
pour françois hollande avec emmanuel
macron il ya un président qui pour moi
je considère comme beaucoup de gens que
le quinquennat est terminée en tout cas
politiquement il est terminé c'est à
dire que bien sûr le président va
continuer non mais c'est terminé au
niveau de tours non mais c'est la
réalité vous savez le quinquennat mais
le concurrent l'a connu l'on sait qu en
tant qu inquiets d'un est terminée vous
savez quand vous avez l'alliance
dramatique de la chute du toboggan dans
les sondages qu'on appelle le principe
du toboggan plus le manque de croissance
ça veut dire que c'est terminé on arrête
les réformes après on va faire du
bougisme françois hollande a fait ça
nicolas sarkozy a fait ça également
donc moi s'il fallait réformer les
institutions je dirais qu'il faudrait
revenir un septennat unique je pense que
la proposition de juppé était formidable
mais ça c'est autre chose mais en
réalité aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est pourquoi les français sont si peu
attachés c'est que vous avez vous pouvez
continuer à être président de la
république vous pouvez continuer à
exercer votre imperium et ça personne ne
l'enlève
mais parce que vous êtes très protégée
par les institutions vous pouvez être
ultra minoritaire dans un pays ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui du président de
la
unique très vite ce qui est le cas ce
qui a été le cas de françois hollande ce
qui a été également le cas de nicolas
sarkozy mais continue et finalement à
gouverner et a imposé pendant quatre ans
cinq ans les choses c'est là que ça va
pas je pense que les français disent on
en a marre de ce roi président et c'est
ce qui a notamment sauvé à un moment à
la fin de son premier septennat françois
mitterrand entre 1986 et 88 et le
chiffre étonnant la révélation étonnante
entre les quatre points d'une se sont
lâchés que le l'ancien président est
considéré comme le meilleur de ces
quarante dernières années et comme l'a
noté quelqu'un d'assez cruel ce n'est
pas la prime à l'ancienneté puisque vous
voyez valéry giscard d'estaing arrive
d'un milieu à l'aube au milieu donc
c'est pas la prime c'est pas la prime à
l'âge celui qui a duré plus longtemps il
a fait 14 ans et vous êtes vous est de
cet avis aussi vous pensez que ça a été
le meilleur président franchement j'en
sais rien et pour vous quel a été le
meilleur président c'est le prochain pas
été correct avec son je pense qu'en fait
on a eu des présidents qui ont dans
l'ensemble commis une erreur
fondamentale notamment je pense à
françois mitterrand qui a vraiment
gouverner à contre-courant et qui a
ouvert en fait cette voie de proposer de
promettre à la france dé toute une série
de réformes qui est des angles
extrêmement pertinente mais georges et
la vie sans forcément les financer et
sans regarder comment le reste du monde
tournait et on s'est enfermés dans une
illusion d'un monde d'une france qui
pourrait finalement faire ce qu'elle
voulait et à crédit bien sûr on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile de changer revenir au votre
sondage de tout à l'heure qui était
intéressant sur un point que les
chiffres que vous montriez 56 44
c'est également l'étiage du premier tour
de la présidentielle dire que
globalement sur une portion des français
qui n'ont voté pour des partis qui ne
sont pas des partis de gouvernement
traditionnels ou qui n'ont pas voté et
le reste s'est mobilisée sur sur la sur
un sur un vote de parti gouvernant
messas en dit très long
si aujourd'hui on a quand même pleuré ce
que 60% des français qui n'aiment pas
véritablement la saisie avec lui la
cinquième risque c'est que ça pose un
vrai problème de l'efficacité du système
et je pense qu'on pourra pas continuer
enfin ça c'est un vrai point de vue de
fond mais on va continuer à les poser
sur twitter selon joue emmanuel macron
est un deal un digne héritier de charles
de gaulle est pour l'instant vous êtes
vous répondez non à 82% et cela même
augmenter puisque tout à l'heure c'était
79%
pierre vermeren pour vous le meilleur
président de la vème république
vous savez je suis partie de la
génération j'avais j'étais en seconde
quand françois mitterrand était élu est
on est on a eu tout faux pas oublier 83
on avait déjà eu au bout des deux ans 7
mai mais c'est vrai que le septennat je
pense a été quelque chose qui a sauvé
les deux premiers présidents de votre
liste enfin apparemment pas giscard
d'estaing mais ils ont pu au fond il
avait la durée pour eux ils avaient le
temps maintenant si vous voulez il ya un
bloc voilà il ya une seule d'ailleurs
les français ayant voté 40% législatives
la dernière fois ça veut bien dire
qu'ils sont il considère qu'il ya une
seule impression une seule élection qui
compte est à la mesure de cette élection
présidentielle effectivement ils sont
déçus et tout par tout le système paraît
l'assemblée nationale est entièrement
dans les mains du président d'ailleurs
personne n'y attache une très grande
importance c'est catastrophique bien sûr
en termes d'adhésion aux ambitions on
avait réduit le nombre d'années du
président mais finalement on a renforcé
le pouvoir du président il ya sur
l'époque à l'époque on avait dit parce
que j'ose parler fils enrichira avec la
combler ce que je veux dire sur le sur
françois mitterrand il avait dit il
avait eu cette phrase je suis le dernier
des grands présidents après moi et vous
n'aurez que des comptables et des
banquiers
il s'était pas tout à fait tromper je
pense que c'est un très grand président
parce qu'il a changé la structure de
finance plus y est allemand il a changé
la vie sociétale m'en faut savoir ce que
c'était les années ponia et les
analystes ça vous fait plus ça vous fait
plaisir de voir que françois mitterrand
et le j'ai un peu de mal avec la fin de
règne crépusculaire de françois
mitterrand on n'est pas très fier d'eux
donc je note que françoise vous avez été
là quand même celle qui a dit que
qui a répondu à la question quel était
votre meilleur président là je n'ai pas
eu d'autre réponse il est magnifique
aussi sauf que de gaulle n'est pas moi
qui ai pas pompidou blier mais je suis
d'accord avec vous j'avais beaucoup
d'affection
la question n'était pas positionné dans
les quarante ans précisément macron fait
preuve d'amateurisme c'est ce que nous
dit juniors bryan nous dit c'est la
distance entre la terre de la lune voilà
cela la différence entre de gaulle et
macron mais parfois il arrive que la
lune éclaire la terre macron a fait
l'erreur de construire un vieux parti
par des vieux caciques du système du
bâti et anti mac qu'on salue fidèles
internautes du figaro nous dit je ne
juge pas les propos de macron sur le
fond mais sur la forme c'est
catastrophique qui n'aiment pas le
peuple mais ce qui est encourageant
c'est qu'il mêle macron est encore plus
le meilleur score que françois hollande
qui viennent de l'espoir trois rendez
vous dans quatre ans d'ici là on va
écouter ce qui s'est passé hier place
beauvau c'était on a beaucoup commenté
la gestuelle l'événement on est
peut-être passé un petit peu à côté du
fait que dans les douars philippe habits
du temps à arriver et que selon les
informations le lisais même ne savait
pas où et edouard philippe et ce qu'il
faisait et ils étaient en colère
il n'en reste pas moins que tout ça à
passer dans mes une déconcentrés du tout
ça dans le fait qu'on n'a pas écouté ce
que disait ce que disait gérard selon
alors on a un peu évoquée hier mais
ça mérite quand même qu'on l'écouté on
le ré écoute et on y revient justement
je crois vraiment que dans la périphérie
parisienne
on ne peut plus continuer à travailler
commune par commune
il faut une vision d'ensemble pour
recréer de la mixité sociale
parce que aujourd'hui on vit côte à côte
et je le dis toujours moi je crains que
demain on vive face à face et donc nous
sommes en phase de problèmes immenses et
il ya un homme qui partage ce diagnostic
c'était ce matin bruno retailleau le
patron des sénateurs et l'eire qui
s'exprimait sur europe 1 je pense comme
gérard collomb que le séparatisme le
communautarisme est en train de gagner
du terrain
il faut tirer la sonnette d'alarmé on a
déversé des milliards des subventions on
a voulu acheter la paix sociale
résultat on a fait prospérer le désordre
et non pas la loi de la république
c'est très inquiétant d'entendre un
ministre qui part en faisant ce constat
si j'ai bonne mémoire
françois hollande dans son livre
testament a fait un constat très proche
je ne sais plus les mots exacts mais
c'était proche et nicolas sark de
partitions nom dans le livre non pas de
testament mais dans le livre ouais
nous qu'on ferait nicolas sarkozy avait
déjà fait ce constat d'une autre manière
dans sa campagne présidentielle et
finalement on voit que douze ans après à
peu près à ce travail de désagrégation
sociale
se perpétuer le ministre de l'intérieur
qui fait ce constat quitte le
gouvernement sur ces propos alors qu'il
était quelqu'un de très proche
le prochain ne sera forcément moins
proche à priori du président de la
république donc il va encore être
pouvoir agir - donc je comprends que il
ya lieu d'être très inquiet enfin ou ou
alors enfin il est mieux informé que
nous a priori on entend parler nous de
faits divers on entend parler d'actes
terroristes qui sont reclassés en fait
divers on n'arrive pas à faire la part
des choses on n'arrive pas à avoir une
vision globale
on sent bien que les choses nous ce dont
on peut juger c'est que dans les
transports en commun dans les villes sur
les trottoirs on voit bien qu'il ya une
dégradation delà de l'esprit collectif
ça on le voit après les affaires
criminelles on n'est pas en état jugé
mais il est évident qui se passe quand
même des choses très inquiétante
si le ministre de l'intérieur lui-même
le dit on est obligé d'être d'accord
c'est ce que je viens de citer la
concurrence mais c'est ce que disent nos
confrères du point avec leurs numéros
qui est consacré à ce qu'ils appellent
des sagouins mais on est impressionné de
voir la montée de ce que chevènement
appelé l'incivilité françoise degois
françois hollande puisqu'on parlait de
lui donc il évoque le risque
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est la partition
de mémoire c'est ce qu'il dit dans le
dans le livre la présidente ne devrais
pas dire ça
en tout cas ce qu'ils disent est bien
c'est qu'on ne peut pas laisser
d'intérim pour des questions de sécurité
ce que oui alors moi je voudrais quand
même revenir je suis pas soupçonnable de
défendre émanait vaqueront mais quand
même à sa décharge avoir un tel ministre
de l'intérieur sait très bien que gérard
collomb sans lag mais la façon c'est lui
qui l'a choisi lui sinon été très propre
mais comme on donne un vieux grognards
on lui donne ce très beau poste où il a
été inexistant là strictement quasiment
rien fait gérard collomb que c'est que
oui à la valeur est très présent à lyon
non au ministre de l'intérieur à
l'extérieur la réalité c'est que je
trouve ça assez rocambolesque
irresponsable de la part du ministre
l'intérieur quel que soit son amertume
parce qu'on sent bien que on est quand
même dans une rupture quasiment
affective avec emmanuel macron un tas
pas été loyal toi non plus voilà je m'en
vais je trouve ça détestable sur le
perron de
vos de faire ce type de constat à
l'emporte-pièce puis on vient à côté on
va se retrouver face à face qu'est ce
que ça veut dire mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire se trouvait que c'était un peu
désinvolte
je trouve ça une nonchalance d'une
désinvolture et surtout d'une forme de
perversion je vais loin dans ce que je
dis je trouve ça très pervers d'abord
oui mais c'est pervers
comment vous qualifier ça autrement
voilà quelqu'un qui depuis un an et demi
et aux affaires
la france elle s'est relevée elle s'est
quand même tenu debout ensemble en 2015
on sait tous de toulouse on vit les
français vivent avec cette idée que le
terrorisme existaient ils vivent avec
effectivement ces sauvageons dont
parlait chevènement au jour le jour ces
incivilités guimond il se joue à présent
ces vitesses de jeunes armés et non
allez les sauvageons ces événements ils
se tiennent ensemble la france se tient
debout quand même si on est un peuple
super raisonnable bien plus que ceux qui
nous gouvernent souvent et voilà gérard
collomb qui en partant nous dit allez
ciao un cadeau pour vous savez quoi
c'est le feu ça va bientôt mettre le feu
c'est insupportable inacceptable ce qui
est encore plus inacceptable c'est que
pendant un an et demi il a géré ça
qu'at-il fait 'nos et l'expert des
questions de sécurité sur ce plateau
s'appelle avec seulement neuf experts
n'ont pas forcément mais aussi à bord en
tout cas observateurs on a travaillé sur
ces questions
non mais je crois que gérard collomb dit
quelque chose extrêmement intéressant on
peut rapprocher d'ailleurs ça ça son
testament si je puis dire à celui d'en
vendre au registre qu'a fait nicolas
hulot dire que véritablement on est face
à des gens qui partent des affaires pour
des raisons diverses et variées on peut
les commenter mais qui disent quelques
jours extrêmement profond et et qui
dresse un constat très préoccupant et il
y en a d'autres qu'on pourrait aborder
les problèmes immenses par exemple vous
venez toutes les problématiques de
démographie à l'échelle planétaire bien
sûr le climat bien sûr nationale bien
sûr le d'accord bien sûr que l'europe
n'a pas les preuves de quartier la
république qui ne passent plus les le
communautarisme l'islamisme rampant
qu'on avait vraiment pas encore arrêté
on peut les prendre les uns priseur tous
tout n'est pas négatif à l'intégration
française qui marche pas très bien le
fait que l'état d'esprit national quand
on veut parler de simplement d'identité
ou de dire qu'est ce qui fait corps
qu'est ce qui fait nation parler
simplement du drapeau bleu blanc rouge
c'est compliqué enfin tout ça fait qu'on
a un problème de fond majeures d'une
idée nationale de capacité à mobiliser
en deux temps en temps il ya des mêmes
d'événements
même de résilience quand il se passe ça
ou ça parce qu'on fait un peu solidarité
mais c'est quand même très compliqué non
pardon françois je crois qu'on est on
est une autre nation elle est très
fragile elle est fracturée de multiples
manières et qu' on est dans une période
en fait on savait en fait le problème
c'est qu'on est sur la défensive on a
été une nation conquérante et offensive
pendant des siècles et demi exactement
depuis long mais depuis que la
mondialisation est vraiment passés par
les camps jouent plus la compétition
internationale comme on devrait la joue
et on n'est que sur la défensive et on a
toujours des postures et ça va de la
posture et l'imposture ya qu'un pas et
on a des discours politiques qui sont
décalées
on ne dit pas la réalité poignée
l'europe aujourd'hui on est en train
encore en train de faire semblant y
compris au niveau des manuels macro on
devrait mettre les pieds dans le plat
pour écouter ça marche pas on va refaire
l'europe on va s'en occuper le dire la
vérité au peuple au lieu de faire
semblant et donc cette façon là
évidemment elles perturbent les gens et
comme en plus les gens qui nous dirigent
ne sont pas exemplaires on en vient à
des phénomènes d'instabilité parce que
les gens qui retombe sur eux j'ai plus
confiance au système marche pas léser
les politiques sont pas exemplaires
donc je me fais je fais ma vie et tant
pis je jette mon mégot jeu je conduis
comme je peux cette espèce de prometic
l'aele et de profonde et elle est
vraiment ancré au gers si on n'a pas
cette approche là des français de la
réalité on continuera à faire semblant
je trouve tout en haut rhin clash pierre
vers 20h juste je m'entends de ces
questions justement de ces sessions de
partitions de problèmes immenses vous
ayez analyser très avec beaucoup
d'acuité les attentats des attentats de
bruxelles est ce que justement le tout
communautarisme qui a peu
accélérer ce phénomène vous savez il ya
quelque chose qui est très simple qui
s'appelle le trafic de drogue qui est le
principal trafic
organisée dans c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'économie des cités c'est aux minimes
ils ont dit que ce chiffre
ça concerne 1 milliard ou 2 milliards
d'euros en réalité ça concerne beaucoup
plus c'est une activité qui rémunère des
faits vivre d'ailleurs de manière
directe ou indirecte probablement des
millions de personnes à la fois ici au
maghreb notamment cette activité elle se
déploie
on en parle c'est un marronnier tiens on
va légaliser
et puis l'année d'après on recommence ce
sujet c'est une sorte de jeu médiatique
mais la gangrène qu'elle entraîne dans
la jeunesse parce que les jeunes garçons
de nombreux quartiers au fond entre
travail et péniblement 10 ans à l'école
et ce en créant une ambiance de
sensations basées les organisations
si vous voulez on al'impression souvent
que les cités qui ne bouge pas dans
lesquelles il ya peu de délinquance sont
des cités qui sont bien tenues mais
elles sont tenues par qui elles sont
tenues par les par les trafiquants qui
maintient l'ordre ils le font bien placé
pour le savoir et tout le monde le sait
et les choses continuent mais je on peut
vraiment se demander jusqu'où jusqu'en
jusqu'à quand
c'est quand exactement ce que dit à nos
internautes élan qui ils font tous le
constat et nous ferons tous rien
bravo cet hymne aironi bien sûr marque
pourtant quand même du temps de colons
les moyens pour l'intérieur ont augmenté
comme ils avaient augmenté sous françois
hollande après avoir diminué
facialement sur nicolas sarkozy qui
avait diminué le nombre de personnes en
fin de fonctionnaires de police en tout
cas au total mais ils en avaient mis
plus sur le terrain parce qu'il ya des
tâches administratives qui avait été
laissée à des gens qui ne savaient pas
de photos de deux fonctions deux
policières oui les moyens ont augmenté
mais ce qui a été très surprenant et
hier moi je l'écouté son discours iger
j'ai vraiment écouté le fond du discours
pas uniquement le jeu sur la montre le
fait qui poireautent et les bras croisés
que edouard philippe
il prenait place à ces gens fous ces
légumes cesser les crimes politiques sur
le fond quand il dit que l'ue n'ait
donné narcotrafiquants ont pris le pas
sur la république dans les quartiers
quand il parle d'une gestion non
maîtrisée des de la masse salariale des
effectifs de police du ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est flippant c'est flippant c'est
flippant de la part d'un homme qui a été
chargée de la sécurité des français
effectivement pendant un an et demi et
dont on nous dit donc c'est super de
disques vous inquiétez pas la situation
gérer cette inquiétude et a retrouvé
d'ailleurs sur lefigaro.fr c'est le
sondage le thème du sondage aux hawks a
fait pour le figaro et france info et
qui est à retrouver dès ce soir sur
lefigaro.fr ouais je veux juste la
parole à la trêve et juste pour
compléter ce qu'ils aient marre que l'on
a très justement le budget de la dhuys à
l'intérieur 91% ces masses salariales
voilà donc il reste 9 % pour faire le
reste avec des commissariats des moyens
des problématiques technologiques
voilà tant qu'on n'aura pas réglé cette
question là aussi et peut-être revue les
cartes police/gendarmerie enfin retour
au fond des et peut-être créer un
continuum davantage parce que si on n'a
pas de bonne police sur un pas de bonne
justice enfin tout ça aide
et vice versa donc voilà il ya des
sujets majeurs ils sont pour l'instant
on des survols 1 là je voudrais dire que
par rapport à gérard collomb aussi en
vert sur le plan politique donc on est
tous d'accord sur la gravité du constat
heureusement mais sur le plan politique
vous savez et lyon
gérard collomb il n'est pas attendu à
lyon 1re soyons très clairs
gérard collomb il va être en difficulté
il a besoin de revenir et vous savez
lyon se construit toujours contre la
capitale donc je vous fiche mon billet
que dans les quelques jours qui viennent
on va avoir du col en non-stop qui va
taper qui va taper et qui va se
dissocier de plus en plus si vous voulez
de emmanuel macron et c'est en ça que je
dis qu'il ya une double responsabilité
des gérard collomb la première c'est en
tant que ministre l'intérieur vous
raconter ses salades pendant 3 minutes
sur un perron qui sont vraies ou fausses
mais qu'ils font quand même flipper à
peu près tout le monde parce que nous on
n'est même pas les spécialistes
spécialité on est assez protégé
l'imaginer les gens qui regardent ça
dans leur ville de 15000 habitants
vous avez des petites infractions
quotidien ces incivilités
voilà et en plus de ça il va utiliser ça
en plus de ça bientôt il va nous faire
croire qu'ils partent parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas les moyens de sa politique
est là moi je refuse de tomber dans le
cinéma de gérard collomb pardonnez moi
c'est dur mais j'ai pas envie d'entendre
gérard collomb nous dit qui part parce
qu'il n'a pas eu les moyens de sa
politique
ça c'est pas vrai c'est chicago et qu'il
augmente les forces de l'ordre quelques
hommes soit c'est parce qu'on sait très
bien ce qui est grenoble on sait très
bien il sait très bien ce que c'est et
quartier de houaiqa à grenoble il ya des
problèmes qui sont supérieures au reste
du pays non je pense qu'à grenoble il ya
des problèmes récurrents dans un certain
nombre de cités de 25 ans à grenoble
je vais vous citer à la seyne-sur-mer
dans le var ça fait 25 ans que ça dure
grenoble s'éteint trouvé c'est une
enquête qui a été fait d'ailleurs dans
les pages sur les figaro qui sont à
retrouver sur lefigaro.fr violent je
laisse la parole aux internautes et
notamment donc qui répondait à la
question est on bien entendu le
testament de gérard collomb en termes de
sécurité
56 % répondent non et moi je suis partie
des 56 % j'ai redécouvert ce matin et 44
% répondent oui
baldino je vous coupe ce qui est
terrible c'est que dans son exposé dans
son exposé sur son à son crédit il nous
parle des poly de la prise de reconquête
des quartiers
donc c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy
appelait les flics qui était celle
d'aller jouer au foot avec les brigands
et et la police de quartier mise en
place par jose pas tout à fait mais ceci
dit je veux dire quand il parle de
narcotrafiquants
quand il dit que la situation va devenir
ingérable dans les quartiers c'est pas
des mecs qui jouent au foot geek dont on
a besoin géré la limite après on va nous
demander aux français vous dis c'est
l'armée qui font envoyer dans les
quartiers a grenoble c'est pas des mecs
qui jouent au foot assure babineau nous
dit l'absence de réel plan banlieue est
très inquiétant je suis assez d'accord
avec collomb il faut une vision globale
mirindi l'état ne protège pas les
policiers les gendarmes qui craignent
des représailles dès qu'ils font
respecter la loi
babine ou encore nicolas hulot tire le
même constat il faut qu emmanuel macron
donne les moyens à ses ministres d'agir
sur le fond et c'est de ce discours que
refuse françoise degois pour enfin
limites
vous savez je veux juste une question
vincent a posé et tout le monde va
sourire imaginez vous si emmanuel macron
était à 62 % dans les sondages
est-ce que vous pensez que nicolas il
aurait démissionné et gérard collomb
aussi je pose juste la question les gens
répondent très bien vous pouvez répondre
justement à cette question qui est posée
par françoise degois dont on se
souviendra qu'elle est quand même
journaliste je crois surtout que nos
cieux que l'on en avait le ras-le-bol
des frasques de macron une volée puce
porter caution c'est ce que nous y clj
et anti mac
l'insécurité est un problème majeur en
france mais cela n'intéresse pas le
gouvernement
c'est une vraie question ça justement
sur cette question sur le terrorisme
on voit toujours le gouvernement
s'implique et dessus mais sur la
sécurité depuis les lois soient sacrés
de loi sarkozy début des années 2000 il
ya
on n'a jamais entendu à une implication
véritable du gouvernement non il ya une
continuité sur les politiques publiques
entre ce qu'avait été fait ce qui était
démontée ma transcrire et installé avec
la police de sécurité du quotidien mais
c'est toujours pareil tout ça c'est des
politiques de temps très long donc tant
qu'il ya pas de continuité on a démonté
abandonnait les services de
renseignement proximité avec des vraies
problématiques de conséquences y compris
rh
donc on est toujours avec une gestion
des affaires publiques et court termiste
budgétaire c'est vrai qu'on a démonté
une partie du ministère de la défense
sous sarkozy parce qu'on considérait que
finalement il y avait plus de menace à
nos portes donc ça valait le coup de
faire des économies
maintenant on remonte tout ça c'est
compliqué tant qu'il n'y a pas cette
espèce de vision un peu long terme j'ai
pas trop avoir des visions comme les
autres parce que quand on a des visions
faut les voir le médecin
mais il faut quand même avoir un peu de
planification et le jeu politique là
dessus et très dévastateur comme en plus
on n'a plus beaucoup de moyens et
comment on a un électorat à séduire
alors on fait des promesses mais après
il faut les assumer donc je le
déshabille paul pour habiller pierre
au regard des sujets sur lesquels pardon
il faut de la continuité l'éducation
nationale la justice
la police avait pas tout refaire non
mais j'ai dit non mais non je refais pas
tout je sais ça parce que juste le vent
et avoue qu'il faut de la continuité est
un autre sujet sur lequel je voudrais
charlotte viens de me rappeler abondera
est justement qui nous reste plus que 10
minutes et je vais pas vu ton film c'est
à dire que la discussion était
intéressante et il ya encore deux sujets
sur la table et je voudrais qu on les
aborde tous les deux le premier c'est
sur la sécurité sociale alors c'est une
info moi qui m'a beaucoup intéressant
que j'en ai entendu parler ce matin marc
devant la confiance dans la conférence
de rédaction du figaro sans trahir de
secret je croyais que la sécu était
arrivé à l' équilibre mais ça ne suffit
pas pour la cour des comptes qui veut
qu' il y ait encore des efforts pour
remplir les comptes de la sécu oui la
force et le traditionnel exercice de
didier migaud le premier président de la
cour des comptes qui chaque année rend
son avis sur l'état des comptes sociaux
il fait les congeler les comptes locaux
ils font les contenus construction les
comptes de l'état distincts là c'est la
sécu et ben effectivement on a vu que
quand on a présenté le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
la semaine dernière on nous a présenté
que pour la première fois depuis 17 ans
on allait revenir dans le vert en 2019
avec un bel excédent de 700 millions
d'euros ce qui est formidable parce
qu'effectivement le dernier oui mais
quand on regarde la course c'est vrai
qu' on est on est vraiment sur une pente
qui etc etc etc et ascensionnel de
réduction du déficit c'est indéniable
sauf que quand on regarde comment ça
c'est fait on se rend compte qu'il ya
deux raisons pour lesquelles on et
revient dans son regard vers le premier
c'est que comme pour le budget de l'état
et le déficit de l'année dernière de
l'encens de l'état on à l'axé la
croissance qu'on a dopé la croissance a
dopé les recettes
les rentrées de cotisations et de
contributions ce qui fait que les
dépenses sont pas freinés véritablement
c'est les recettes qui ont explosé donc
du coup l'un dans l'autre on a plus de
recettes on a des dimensions qui lance
on a ça va beaucoup n'y a pas de
réformes structurelles
non et deuxièmement là où là où il met
le doigt et c'est avec une conséquence
importante didier migaud s'est il fait
de dire en vérité l'année dernière ce
qui s'est passé c'est que pour tenir nos
engagements on à serrer le kiki des
hôpitaux et on a laissé dériver les
dépenses de ville c'est à dire les
médecins et donc est la résultante
c'était que le déficit des hôpitaux a
été historique a été multiplié par 2
l'année dernière tout simplement pour
pouvoir afficher une belle image et ça
c'est un vrai problème est la
conséquence que ça donne c'est que la
cour des comptes dit il faut contraindre
plus les médecins il faut que les
dépenses de ville
c'est à dire les transports sanitaires
ça veut dire les soins de kiné etc soit
beaucoup plus encadrée parce que sinon
ça va on va revenir dans le rouge très
vite et ça c'est pas possible
rapidement france aux ouïes basse et les
villages potemkine que seul bercy est
capable de construire mais parce que
c'est le travail de bercy aussi de faire
des affichages c'est comme ça c'était
sur les comptes de la sécu louer sur les
cordes de la sécu après ce qu'il faut
plus taxer l'alcool moi qui suis une
fumeuse invétérée et qu'il boit pas je
me dis après tout pourquoi pas tout le
monde doit être taxé voilà je dise
possible de violer les principes
d'égalité voilà oui et puis contrôler
les dépenses oui je suis d'accord tous
en règle générale mais attention moi la
seule chose qui m'affole c'est de toute
façon les hôpitaux mais là j'ai une
vision stratosphérique qui n'est pas la
vôtre marque mais le sentiment que les
hôpitaux sont tellement démunis en
termes de moyens en terme de d'urgence
en termes de personnel je regardais les
gens qui sont en grève la l'hôpital
pinel prg psychiatrie amiens 3 mois et
demi de grève
ils sont deux infirmiers pour 25 malades
c'est ça moi qui me qui m'apporte à la
limite j'aimerais bien je préférais que
la sécu soit déficitaire mais si les
malades étaient bien soigné voilà encore
du pacs on va devenir très cher de vivre
en france je pense que l'amour donné
fera peut-être qu'on trouve d'autre
solution que cette fois seulement
je voudrais que ça passe quand même
qu'on fasse un peu preuve d'imagination
voilà je trouve que cette solution de
dire bon après tout on peut mettre sur
un même pied tabac et alcool pourquoi
pas mais mais si on passe son temps à
trouver comme solution la taxation
l'augmentation tout ça pour boucher des
trous d'un système qui n'en finit pas
coûté trop cher on trouvera pas voir
l'écran on a augmenté les taxes sur le
tabac ça a eu un effet sur la
consommation et donc ça a un effet sur
les dépenses de santé puisque si les
gens fument moins ils sont moins malades
il ya moins de cancers du poumon et
c'est ce qui est vrai est factuellement
ça se ressent dans les chiffres si on a
fait cet effort là de matière de
prévention et d'anticipation des
problèmes de santé demain sur le tabac
on doit faire exactement la même chose
sur l'alcool parce que l'alcool a les
mêmes désagréments par conséquent super
départ de la politique punitive amont et
sa touche ses limites et puis c'est
peut-être pas forcément la seule bonne
manière quand on veut engager un peuple
donc je m'en veux faire de la politique
autrement engagé un peuple est
systématiquement il ya façon t'es pas
responsable donc je te taxe de table je
te contrôler deux etc
je pense que ce n'est pas la bonne
manière de faire alors oui à court terme
il ya peut-être des mesures de cette
nature-là mais peut-être une autre façon
de faire aussi du reprend les problèmes
à la base
la prévention c'est fondamental la
prévention depuis le très jeune âge
c'est aussi fondamental il faut penser
aux demain et après demain on parlait
politique de temps long voilà ces sujets
là on peut les traiter des tréteaux et
après peut être éviter d'en revenir à
des impôts à des punitions à des taxes à
des contrôles dans la solution c'est
emmanuel macron qui dit arrêtez
d'emmerder les français avec une
taxation sur le vin ce qu'il a dit au
que lorsqu'il a fait visiter le salon de
l'agriculture est que cette idée de taxe
et le vin
elle était portée par une prohibition
des élites d'une partie des élites
anarchique ou françaises notamment qui
est très impressionnant et qui continue
mois après mois année après année
maintenant on a appris il ya quinze
jours que boire un verre de vin ça
risquait de diminuer l'espérance de vie
de 0,1 pour cent vous rendez compte
en réalité si on est sur des
considérations strictement financière il
faut laisser les gens boire parce que la
mortalité s'accentue et ça ne fait pas
du tout ça n'aggrave pas les faits n'en
les finances de la sécurité sociale si
on veut être cynique jusqu'au bout donc
oui c'est triste mais soyons sérieux
rennes et professeur d'université
inspecteur à la cour des comptes un
certain doute marie-cécile nous disent
sécu c'est pas la dépense qui sont
freinées ces les recettes qui ont
explosé bien dit mark hurd reich et
peut-être une idée de turku et
marie-cécile en tout cas on la salue
commence à lui babineau l'alcool tue
donc s'il faut taxer quelque part
pourquoi pas le tabac aussi je voudrais
qu'on passe à une autre question c'est
celle du figaro aujourd'hui le mouvement
mis tous at il eu des effets positifs
sur la société c'est la question qu'on
pose sur lefigaro.fr et pour l'instant
où vous êtes une large majorité à
répondre 60 à 75% très exactement à
répondre non
voici en tout cas ce que on a dit
marlène schiappa qui est secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes s'étaient sur rtl
ça n'a pas bouleversé la donne parce
qu'on ne peut pas changer en un an et
même si la force de mitsou est
incontestable on peut pas changer en un
an des comportements qui sont ancrées
depuis des générations le président de
la république l'avait dit à lui-même en
lançant la grande cause de son
quinquennat pour l'égalité femmes hommes
toute notre société est malade du
sexisme
ça va demander beaucoup travaillent
ensemble pour faire en sorte de guérir
de cette maladie alors je vais vous
citer excusez moi c'est une citation
dont je vous demande bien de mettre des
guillemets ce que je vais dire une
certains d'une chose de paroles qui ont
été tenus je cite c'est donc on verra
comment tu fais la belle avec une jambe
cassée on verra comment tu suces quand
je te déboîterai la mâchoire
t'es juste une truie tu mérites ta place
à l'abattoir t'es juste un démon déguisé
en femme
je te veux te voir brisée en larmes je
dois rendre l'âme je veux devoir
retourner brûler dans les flammes
l'auteur de ces paroles a reçu trois
victoires de la musique
c'était en février dernier et il ne me
semble pas avoir ré entendu ces paroles
à ce moment là alors qu'on se demandait
gravement s'il fallait réécrire l'issue
de la fin la finale les pilotes de la
belle au bois dormant
heureusement si le prince n'a pas fait
un baiser volé oui c'est assez drôle ce
qu'audi je me souviens très bien de
quelqu'un que je connais que j'aime
beaucoup ségolène royal qui s'était
insurgé contre les paroles d'orelsan qui
chantait aux francofolies l1 avait pris
plein la patate ségolène elle a été
condamnée à lille a été conduit en
instance la cour d'appel de versailles
en février 2000 freud il faut avancer
sur les combats et moi je trouve que la
relaxe on a changé il a fait aussi son
mea culpa je veux dire par là que le
combat bits ou alors il ya des gens qui
pensent beaucoup apparemment ça c'est à
moi je pense que ce formidable ça a
libéré complètement la parole ça a
permis aux gens de s'exprimer
c'est un mouvement planétaire je lisais
que aujourd'hui il assure parce que
c'est l'anniversaire je lisais que il ya
même en chine maintenant les chinois
dans société fermée étriqué se sont
emparés de demi tout pour pourparlers
pour dénoncer vous avez des milliers de
plaintes qui ont été déposées
je trouve ça formidable de libérer la
parole des femmes quand même s'il ya
quelques excès il faut libérer la pose
une question ce matin moi j'ai traversé
la rue pour venir ici aussi je t'ai pas
avec mes enfants je cherchais pas du
boulot mais je sais pas si j'ai passé
devant les kiosques à journaux à
l'intérieur il ya moins de journaux
d'ailleurs qui sont à vendre
par contre il ya toujours les devantures
il ya toujours les unes de magazines
pornos 2
su donc si on a balancé le port et le
port de la porcherie à 94 contre la
pornographie était encore légal en mai
la raison de dire ça procède d'un tout
moi je salut vincent le féministe sa
poussette dans tout même moi je suis
très heurtée quand je vois ça mais en
même temps voilà on est quand même dans
un pays de liberté dont orelsan a droit
de chantier ce qu'il chante
après si la justice le permet non mais
voilà la justice l'avait je veux dire un
moment donné des gages au 10 avril à la
justice oui oui mais je vous signale la
justice a décidé mais je vous rappelle
cette polémique
terrible la personne qui a été mise en
accusation pendant des semaines c'est
ségolène pour avoir dénoncé orelsan
chante on chante aux francofolies donc
c'est quand même une inversion de la
charge
maintenant ça change un peu mais voilà
je trouve que ça change et je trouve que
ce qui a changé voyez ça ça arrive très
tard par rapport à l'université quand on
entend ce qui se passait dans les
universités il ya pas si longtemps dans
les années 70 80 et que là c'est la
féminisation qu'à changer les choses
c'est à dire que ce qui se passait en
termes de bons emplois y ont pas le mot
droit de cuissage mais ça y ressemble
fort je pense que c'est quelque chose de
résiduel parce qu'il ya eu un
rééquilibrage notamment entre le parmi
les enseignants parmi les étudiants
aussi mais parmi les premiers des
enseignants c'était un monde d'hommes
et donc c'était un monde qui avait ses
privilèges et il ya un certain nombre de
personnes en ont abusé
encore une fois d'après beaucoup de
témoignages est aujourd'hui me semble
faux pas à vous être trop naïf mais il
me semble qu'il ya eu un certain
équilibre et que les équipes la mixité
ont arrangé les choses d'une manière
importante au moins un secteur après le
show biz parce que ça si vous voulez on
parle du milieu du cinéma on parle de
milieux très particulier quand on parle
de la ferme itou après la société elle
est soumise à des vents le vent des
burqas qui s'ouvre d'arabie saoudite le
vent de la pornographie qui naquit qui
sauvent d'amérique ne m'ont pas l'air
d'améliorer la situation d'ensemble
si on s'intéresse à l'image des
affairistes une ambition si on
s'intéresse à la manière dont un petit
garçon aujourd'hui un petit garçon de 10
ans aujourd'hui découvre les femmes et
la sexualité à travers la prendre
affi je vous laisse selon et j'ai libéré
si l'on se livre la ligne le port
émissaires quand vous recommande et
qu'ils aient disons du servent ces neuf
ans d'ailleurs ben voilà le dernier
dernière nouvelle en tout cas je sais
pas qui est cette presse là mais en tout
cas je peux vous dire que julie témoigne
mon plus profond mépris pour pas dire
autre chose parce que ça c'est
insupportable à tous les il ya
maintenant pour en revenir à la question
de fond je reviens vraiment à la logique
du temps on apprend mathy du taux longs
qui a comme quand on fait une société
quand on bâtit un pays oui non mais je
suis d'accord mais simplement sur
revenons à ce qu'avait proposé monsieur
blanc quelle quantité qu'en l'état il
est arrivé il a dit un projet simple que
j'ai trouvé vraiment pertinents lire
écrire compter respecter autrui
voilà je trouve qu'en 2017 qu'on soit
obligé de dire ça de rappelé à dire
c'est aussi drôle de l'école il ya qu'on
a vraiment failli oui on en aurait
peut-être dû le dire il ya 60 ans et est
dès le départ personne dans l'école je
vois un vrai facteur d'éducation parce
que dans ces cas là je pense que si on
avait appris ça peut-être qu on
respecterait mieux notre environnement
respecté le mieux son prochain et là on
en a pour deux générations avant
d'arriver à remettre le truc sur les
rails on continuera le débat d'ailleurs
continue dans les colonnes du figaro et
dans les pages débats aux ions évident
mais pardon marque non déformée et en
plus je sais que vous avez beaucoup de
choses à dire notamment sur la
pornographie vous avez été vous avez
tenu des propos très fort
j'étais là cette place est effectivement
un art du mot pour vous changer la
société et ça a changé le rapport des
hommes aux femmes
je trouve qu'être une bonne chose et
avec les toute révolution provoque des
effets négatifs et
il fallait en passer par là et c'est
très bien et moi je suis content d'être
un homme dans une société où la parole
des femmes s'est libérée ce qui est le
plus important c'est une mère femme qui
a obtenu le prix nobel de physique et
l'égalité salariale c'est ce que nous
dit blueberry c'est important c'est
également le baiser pas volée car reçu
marc landré de françoise des voix et
robes qui nous dit je ne sais pas trop
ce que me tout mais dans ma campagne
l'égalité hommes femmes est assez
présente je finis par vous recommander
puisqu'on parle de
deux femmes dont la parole se libère
croque la pomme c'est le nouveau
spectacle le nouveau ou man one woman
show de caroline vigneaux et c'est à
lire la critique qu'en fait notre
concerne atteint difficilement dans le
figaro salaires désopilant et le titre
ces femmes je vous aime et on ne fera
pas julien clerc pour la fin de cette de
cette émission mais c'est effectivement
le sentiment
le sentiment qui nous anime ce soir
merci beaucoup et à très vite sur fear
alive
[Musique]